should say of course the University of
Virginia has produced famous senators
business leaders journalists but never
an NCAA basketball champion until now we
can say Virginia is number one after
being Texas Tech last night 85 to 77 in
overtime an extraordinary turnaround
after one of the most famous defeats in
March Madness history a year ago
thousands of students at the University
in Charlottesville filled the streets to
celebrate the headline of the daily
progress newspaper reads believe it at
CBS News morning Saturday morning Cohoes
Dana Jacobson is at the site of the
Final Four in Minneapolis Dana good
morning John good morning and
congratulations to you I should say
right off the bat you know they're
tearing down that temporary Court behind
me where just hours ago Texas Tech and
Virginia gave us a national title game
for the ages
Virginia in just one season going from
that one seed that lost to a 16 to one
shining moment
[Applause]
it was an epic comeback a year in the
making a team who suffered an historic
first round loss at the hands of a 16
seed last season now national champions
for the first time in history claiming
victory over Texas Tech both teams
battled the entire game but with just
under 13 seconds left on the clock
Virginia's DeAndre hunter hit a
game-tying three-pointer the game went
into overtime where Virginia took the
lead and never looked back
the feeling after the final buzzer
hysteria fans flooded the streets in
Charlottesville celebrating basketballs
ultimate redemption story it's a goal we
set out the beginning of the season we
knew we were going bounce back from last
year and we achieved our dreams that's
all we want and these guys came to fight
in this title and now were the chance
the Final Fours most outstanding player
virginia's kyle guy says this is what
the team played for all season long to
be able to hug each other it was
confetti going everywhere and say we did
it the greatest feeling I've ever felt
in basketball Virginia head coach Tony
Bennett called that loss last year the
painful gift and if people have heard
the quote that he's used from the TED
talk to motivate his team all season you
know it by now but Gail it's worth
sharing again
that adversity if used properly will buy
you a ticket to a place you couldn't
have gone otherwise couldn't say it any
better myself Congrats to Virginia Wow
Dana that's so good say it again I
didn't get to write it down
say it again okay the adversity if used
properly will buy you a ticket to a
place you couldn't have gone otherwise
love that thank you Dana Jacobson I
stayed up late to watch and when it went
into overtime I would know then yes you
wanted to see how it is gonna turn out
really looks such a great game and
apparently after it was over there's a
tradition that some people engaged in
where the lawn which is the area that is
a part of Jefferson's original
Academical village they they run down
the lawn with only their birth their
birthday suit and apparently that was
going on quite a lot less oh you must be
very proud I am so no cars were turned
over but I think some stomachs okay also
known as buck naked it's all good all
right